well watching this situation as well
Michelle Turner is here with news about
Mischa Barton whom we all first got to
know on the OC and this is scientist er
it is Nancy there's a lot of people that
are concerned today about her that's
because she was hospitalized yesterday
after a really bizarre meltdown and now
we have new details from the scene half
naked screaming rambling and falling
over backwards it got chaotic outside
Misha's apartment in West Hollywood a
Sheriff's Department spokesperson tells
et they received a disturbance call
yesterday at 7:15 a.m. for a female that
was yelling an ambulance firetruck and
deputies rushed to her home authorities
say the actress was making incoherent
statements and was then voluntarily
transported to a nearby hospital for
mental evaluation barton celebrated her
31st birthday two days ago and has since
deleted tweets in from her account
yesterday red thank you all for all the
birthday messages XOXO in previous years
it just didn't feel right or everything
else that was going on in my life last
year misha seemed ready for a comeback
by appearing on Dancing with the Stars
but she struggled in the competition you
know it's an intense experience I can't
do another
she'd been mostly out of the limelight
since her DUI arrest in 2007 and another
headline making mental breakdown in 2009
Nisha was hospitalized on an involuntary
psych hold but just a month later seemed
back on track she's amazing I mean she's
here to work it's really surprising to
see just how great she is doing so many
people have been really supportive I
mean it's amazing her close friendship
with dancing partner Artem continued
even after the show have you an art and
been keeping in touch uh yeah we talked
[Music]
you